hey guys my name is Jess it is the first
of September and you're watching
gamespot use + up a British Telecom a
multinational telecommunications company
based in the UK is suing valve BTW has
claimed valve infringed on its patents
regarding a broad range of products and
services including Steam library steam
chat steam messaging and steam
broadcasting ptc valve infringed on four
patents one of which relates generally
to providing users with content that
originates from multiple subscription
services and delivering it through a
single portal where a customer may
access content VT also claims that valve
infringed on its patent related to
storing and transmitting messages to and
from the server if you haven't had
enough patents by now BTW are finally
claiming infringement on a technology
patent that allows for a multi-user
display system and method for
controlling a communal display that
includes at least two independent
workstations and an interface server for
connection to a data network in normal
people words BTW a claiming ownership
over the technologies which run valves
steam platform although as you may have
questioned at this point youtube twitch
battlenet and plenty of other services
would also be targeted by this logic BTW
claims they've been trying to get in
touch with valve since october of last
year while valve has presumably been too
busy working on all those third
installments were waiting on after two
years of back and forth the lindsay
lohan vs. take two lawsuit has
officially been thrown out if you
somehow missed all this ridiculousness a
Lohan tried to sue take two and twenty
fourteen claiming they used her likeness
in GTA 5 without permission earlier this
year it looked like take two might be in
hot water as Lohan won a preliminary
victory when the publishers motion to
dismiss the case was tonight however
today a judge threw out the case as a
result of the First Amendment
protections a similar case filed by the
daughter of a mob boss Karen Gravano was
also dismissed the ruling states even if
we accept plaintiffs contentions that
the video game depictions are close
enough to be considered representations
of the respected plaintiffs plaintiffs
claims should be dismissed because this
video game
does not fall under the statutory
definitions of advertising or trade GTA
5 was deemed a work of fiction and
satire lohan is still free to appeal so
for better or worse this might not be
the last word on this one finally a
Nintendo Direct was held today so we've
got all the news about what's having you
away from them a company announced a new
Pikmin game for 3d asked you out next
year a new Mario sports game for the 3ds
called Mario sports superstars and that
Super Mario maker is on its way to 3ds
as is Yoshi's woolly world animal
crossing new leaf is adding amiibo
support in December and of course there
are new Zelda amiibo figurines on their
way Zelda Skyward Sword fans can also
enjoy the fact that the game is now
available on the wii u eshop for all the
other tidbits from today's Nintendo
Direct check out our story on gamespot
that is everything you have you today do
head to gamespot for stories on
titanfall two and battlefield one and
I'll be back with the top five stories
of the week tomorrow